one of the most common motions we see in
our everyday lives is the path of an
object moving thrown and moving through
space now this type of motion has a very
famous name called projectile motion and
when we look at it let's introduce a
coordinate system I hat and J hat here's
our y plus y axis and our plus X axis
then in order to understand the
kinematics of this motion we would like
to apply Newton's second law
so separately we'll draw our object it
has gravitational force acting downward
remember our unit vectors in the J hat
direction and so when we write our
equations of motion F equals MA we have
two different directions in the J hat
direction we have the gravitational
force downward minus mg and remember
here that G is our positive quantity 9.8
meters per second and we have ma Y
Newton's second law equates these two
different things and that's we'll write
it like that so those two quantities are
equal and so our conclusion is that the
acceleration is equal to minus G in the
Y direction now likewise keep in mind
that we have our horizontal direction as
well and notice there we're now assuming
that there's no horizontal forces in the
real world there can be all types of air
resistances but here for the simplicity
of this model we have no horizontal
forces so we have zero equals ma X and
so we have our separate equation ax
equals zero now both of these equations
are equations that we've already been
working with in kinematics here we have
a constant acceleration and here we have
zero acceleration so using the results
that we had earlier from integration we
can write down the equations of motion
in the Y and the X directions first
we'll write the velocity V Y as a
function of time is equal to some in
value and because the acceleration is
negative minus GT you can test your
integration technique to see that and
the position as a function of time
remember is just some constant value
this is our constant Y naught and we
have plus V y naught t minus one-half GT
squared again doing integration now the
horizontal equation of motion the X of T
because there's no acceleration in the
horizontal direction this is a constant
value given by the initial value of the
component of the velocity in the X
direction and the position X of T is
then equal to some initial position plus
VX not T and so those are our functions
of time for little components of the
velocity and the components of position
now for our particular example it's much
easier here we have X not equal to zero
notice that our object is starting at
the origin and so that tells us that X
as a function of time is just V X naught
T I'm dropping the parentheses T
remember that's not a product it's just
a function of time and given this fact
that tells us that T is X divided by B X
naught and now I can take this value of
T and put it into our vertical equation
and I get V Y is some initial value plus
V y naught X over V X naught
substituting for t minus one-half g x
squared over V X naught squared when we
describe projectile motion we had a
equation describing Y as a function of T
an equation describing X as a function
of T the horizontal motion the vertical
motion and here we have a separate
equation which is describing the Y as
function of X notice there is no time
involved in this equation now let's try
to look at graphically what we're seeing
here so for instance when we look at a
plot of the motion of y versus of X we
can see the vertical component going up
and down and we can see the horizontal
component moving to the right while the
object is following this trajectory and
this is a parabolic trajectory of Y as a
function of X now if we wanted to
actually plot out Y as a function of T
then here we can look at the simulation
where we're just looking at the Y
component and you can see that that
motion too is a parabola however what's
crucial to look at is that it's Y as a
function of T and not Y as a function of
X finally we can look at the horizontal
motion and again recall that when we
looked at the trajectory as Y is a
function of X you can see the horizontal
motion component let's plot that
separately X as a function of T and when
we make that plot you can see that this
is just a linear equation in time where
there's some initial condition X naught
and so that's the plot of X as a
function of T and so we see three
separate representations of this motion
Y as a function of X Y as a function of
T and X as a function of T